[Applaudissements]
ouah
samedi 13 juin je me suis rendu à la
manifestation contre les vols violences
policières le racisme pour le mouvement
d'adama traoré j'arrive vers les coups
de 14h il fait beau il ya du monde ya
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
monde
il ya toutes les personnes ya des arabes
ya des noirs ya des blancs des chinois
et pakistanais il ya tout le monde
vraiment tout le monde on est on était
vraiment tous ensemble
tout se passait bien voilà moi ça
faisait une heure une heure et demie que
j'étais là et où tout se passait bien
aucune altercation avec la police ou
qu'une altercation avec personne et là
qu'est ce qu'on voit une dizaine
d'individus
moi j'en ai vu 10 sur le toit on va y
venir
ils ont déroulé une grande banderole de
la génération identitaire ils ont
déployé sa avec des fumigènes pour
vraiment que tout le monde les voit ils
sont se sont mis sur le toit du d'un
grand immeuble juste en face la statue
est là il ya commencé à voir de la
colère tout le monde tout le monde
commençait à être sous pression au
regard des lao jeté des pétards
il n'avait qu'une envie c'est d'enlever
cette banderole là qu'on ne la voyais
plus alors à ce moment là il ya les
voisins ils ont commencé à découper un
petit peu la banderole en disant qu'on
se sente est en fait la haine on sentait
la colère des manifestants des gens qui
étaient là pour le pour le mouvement je
me suis dit en fait là on est tous
ensemble et tous réunis on est tous
soudés et qu'est ce qu'on voit encore
des personnes en fait qui viennent comme
ça en fait face à nous nous nous
provoquer en gros et nous montrer qu'on
est que que voilà on est divisés encore
une fois on que je me suis j'ai regardé
le
regardez le bâtiment et voilà j'ai vu
une goutte cher je me suis dit je vais
grimper un la jarre est clairement à
devant la banderole et tu vois il y
avait cinq 5 6 personnes cachées
derrière un petit tu devrais dire murray
qui a sur le toit parce que de l'autre
côté on a déjà qu'ils essaient d'y
tenter déjà de deux d'accéder à la
banderole donc on voyait un petit peu
qu'ils avaient pas d'une altercation
mais il empêchait de passer mais
vraiment plus loin donc il se doutait
pas il ne doutait pas ces gens là que y
en a un qu'il pouvait arriver clairement
par la façade du bâtiment et a tiré pile
poil sur la banderole il s'est dit
raymond vue il était vraiment ils
étaient étonnés ils étaient tous nés de
nous voir à tous donc j'arrive à la
banderole
ça pète je suis la veille point j'étais
en train vraiment de se détacher les la
banderole tout le monde qui est il
entend les cris incroyable c'est dire
moi je trinque frissonner je suis sous
adrénaline jeunes monter un bâtiment je
suis pas combien d'états ja lors du
petit hack juan lève là déroulé e et de
la gelée jeter en fait sur le balcon
d'en bas se dire on voyait vraiment plus
rien j'ai entendu la foule crie et mercy
mercy
après moi je suis venu à cette
manifestation dont j'ai on va dire j'ai
pu arracher une banderole c'est loin
comparer enfin c'est très peu c'est rien
comparé à ce que les gens y mène comme
combat tous les jours comme à saada
traoré qui mène ce combat là depuis
depuis maintenant quatre ans je crois
donc courage a le courage à tous le
monde courage à ceux qui sont dans dans
dans une même situation
[Musique]